a stark warning from the International
Monetary Fund the global economy is
forecast to shrink by 3% this year that
would make it the steepest fall since
the Great Depression in the 1930s in
Asia countries are scrambling to respond
to the economic fallout caused by the
coronavirus there is no doubt the
pandemic has pushed down the world
economy I recognize it it's based on the
fact that it is such a difficult
situation as the IMF points out various
people are saying various things about
the duration of how long these measures
to prevent further spread of infection
will continue going forward the Japanese
government announced a 1 trillion dollar
stimulus package last week and is under
pressure to hand out even more cash that
package includes payouts of $2,800 to
households whose income is judged to
have been hit by the coronavirus
officials now say the government is
considering whether to pay $900 to every
citizen regardless of income Japan
declared a state of emergency in Tokyo
and six other areas last week and urged
people to cut social interactions by 70
percent in New Zealand Prime Minister
just Cinda arden announced that
ministers and public service chief
executives would take a 20% pay cut for
the next six months I absolutely accept
that this is not going to change the
government books but for us it was about
leadership a lot of people were taking a
huge hit right now I do not want the
people who feel it to be the people on
the front line our lower middle income
earners non-essential services in New
Zealand have been closed for the past
three weeks and economic activity has
slowed significantly the country appears
to have successfully reduced the spread
so far but the Prime Minister has warned
the low number of new infections does
not necessarily mean the battle is won
the government is due to decide next
week whether it will extend the lockdown
Florence lui al Jazeera